et philippe bas et donc notre invité ce
soir dans vpl bonsoir merci pour soi
notre invitation président ait l'air de
cette commission des lois et ancien
président de cette commission denquête
benalla fizi bas qu'est ce que vous
répondez au premier ministre qu'on vient
d'entendre longueur et qui parle de vous
commission des lois elle a fait son
travail avec l' empire sur muriel jourda
c'est de travail pluraliste il dépasse
les clivages politiques
nos rapporteurs se sont entendus après
des heures et des heures de travail et
sur les termes d'un rapport
il a été présenté à la commission des
lois hier puis il a été présenté à la
presse et toutes les auditions c'est à
dire près de 50 heures d'audition ont
été intégralement publics au fond il est
vrai juge de notre travail ce sont les
centaines de milliers de français qui
ont suivi les auditions et pour ce qui
nous concerne et je parle en mon nom
mais aussi au nom des rapporteurs
nous avons achevé notre tâche nous avons
conduit au plus loin qu'il était
possible aux investigations en
considérant que l'oeuvre de vérité
devait se faire et qu'elle devait se
faire publiquement et en toute
transparence et nous ne commentons pas
les commentaires ça ces commentaires
ils appartiennent à ceux qui les font
pour ce qui nous concerne nous
commentons si vous nous le demander
notre rapport nous expliquer notre
travail nous disons aussi notre
attachement à la séparation des pouvoirs
rôle spécifique de la justice et
j'ajoute rôle du parlement dans cette
commission denquête parce que vous savez
c'est commission denquête du parlement
elle travaille pas pour le parlement
elle travaille pour les français parce
que c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme qui leur donne un droit
fondamental de demander compte à tout
agent public de son administration et
nous ont depuis le début héééé je prends
à témoin tous ceux qui ont suivi nos
travaux veiller scrupuleusement d'abord
au respect de notre mandat qui ne
portait pas sur les agissements de
monsieur wade à la place de la
contrescarpe le 1er mai à paris mais sur
les défaillances qui avaient pu
apparaître à cette occasion dans le
fonctionnement de l'état pour
premièrement les opérations de maintien
de l'ordre comme celle du 1er mai et
deuxièmement pour la protection des
hautes personnalités et troisièmement
aussi pour apprécier comment les
manquements éventuels peuvent être
sanctionnés nous en sommes restés là
depuis le début notre attention à les
constantes tout point de vue philippa ya
une vraie question constitutionnelle
dans ce dossier est ce que oui ou non le
sénat est un droit de regard et de
critiques sur l'organisation interne de
l'elysée nicole belloubet garde des
sceaux a tenu à faire une mise au point
tout à l'heure elle est au micro de
quentin calme et on l'écouté je vous
fait réagir ensuite je pense que dans ce
domaine là plus que dans tout autre il
faut faire attention à ce qui est écrit
dans le texte constitutionnel qui est
notre norme à tout ce que dit le texte
il dit que on peut mettre en place des
commissions d'enquêté la révision de
2008 qui l'a proposé et c'est une très
bonne chose
c'est commission denquête elles doivent
fonctionner en respectant l'article 24
de la constitution qui précise
évidemment que le rôle du parlement au
delà de voter la loi d'évaluer les
politiques publiques c'est de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
les mots sont extrêmement claires or il
se trouve que dans notre république le
gouvernement il ya dirigé par un premier
ministre il comprend des ministres la
présidence de la république ce n'est pas
le gouvernement
philippa je pense que nos
téléspectateurs ne sont pas experts en
questions constitutionnelles
est ce que oui ou non le sénat a en
outre passé ses fonctions se mêlant de
l'organisation de l'elysée mais
évidemment pas d'abord pour être complet
oui il y a
le fonctionnement des services publics
placés sous l'autorité du gouvernement
mais il ya aussi l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
la sécurité du président de la
république par exemple c'est une
politique publique c'est pas la seule à
faire du président de la république mais
deuxièmement savez vous que la cour des
comptes examine les comptes de l'elysée
que le parlement et en particulier les
rapporteurs spéciaux de la commission
des lois sur les budgets des pouvoirs
publics constitutionnels examine parce
que c'est des impôts des français
les dépenses
de l'elysée qu'un juge peut venir à
l'elysée faire une perquisition dans un
bureau que une grande autorité
indépendante comme la commission d'accès
aux documents administratifs peut
imposer à l'elysée de communiquer des
documents et voyez vous je me demande
dans notre république si le parlement
serait la seule autorité en l'occurrence
tout de même
représentant le peuple souverain qui
n'auraient pas le droit non pas
d'examiner les actes les décisions du
président de la plus que ça c'est
absolument exclu et jamais non mais tu
n'y en cause c'est pas une nuance c'est
une règle de base président de la
république on a le sentiment que
l'exécutif donne un peu de noms dont une
leçon de droit constitutionnel les
meilleurs foyers sont forts une
déception lorsque les sénateurs mais
connaissent le principe de séparation
des pouvoirs
plus loin dans secrétaire général de
l'elysée devrait le savoir mais c'est
parce que je sais ces choses là que je
répond avec assurance et avec aussi
beaucoup de scrupules
je crois que j'espère que ça s'est vu
mais pendant tous nos travaux
à chaque fois qu'une question pouvait
être posée sur par exemple les
agissements de monsieur ban à la haine
ou répondu oh mais ce ne sont pas les
agissements de monsieur benalla qui
intéresse notre commission denquête ce
sont les virtuels dysfonctionnements ou
défaillance de services de l'état est ce
que oui ou non notre démocratie a
atteint la maturité nécessaire pour
admettre que on n'est pas dans un régime
de pleins pouvoirs qu'il y à des
contrôles nécessaires dans l'intérêt
même du peuple français pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'état et que le rôle
du parlement et d'assurer l'exercice de
ce contrôle en respectant pas sur la
constitution effectivement vous ne vous
êtes pas seulement intéressé alexandre
benalla ou à vincent kraz il ya trois
hauts fonctionnaires de trois hauts
responsables de l'elysée que vous mettez
en cause notamment dans cette lettre
adressée à gérard larcher dont alexis
colère lui-même secrétaire général de
l'elysée on a le sentiment que c'est ça
qui fâchent l'exécutif vous êtes allé
trop loin a dit françois patriat
sénateur la république en marche est ce
que vous êtes allé trop loin en pointant
du doigt le travail de trois hauts
responsables de l'elysée
écoutez nous n'allons pas faire deux
poids deux mesures même si de prenons en
compte aussi que les collaborateurs du
président de la république se sont
montrés
très coopératif et rapporter beaucoup
d'informations précises qui était
nécessaire à notre travail et au
contrôle parlementaire et à ce moment là
ils ont tout à fait convenu d'ailleurs
qu' il était tout à fait légitime qu'ils
répondent à nos questions
mais quand eux à la fin du mois de
juillet des collaborateurs du président
nous dise que monsieur benalla n'avait
pas de responsabilité en matière de
sécurité et les citations
c'était avant tout le monde que ça a été
dit est que un mois et demi plus tard on
nous remet la fiche de poste dans
laquelle il est écrit qu'il coordonne
les services de sécurité eh bien nous
disons que pouvons nous faire
nous constatons que là il y a eu d une
part de la vérité qui a été retenu sur
les mots rétention d'information or or
si c'est le cas voyez comme nous
agissons pour permettre aux français
d'exercer leur droit de contrôler si on
nous ment sous serment ou si on retient
une partie de la vérité sous serment
à ce moment là si on laisse faire ça
veut dire que demain les commissions d
enquête parlementaire ne serviront à
rien et que le droit des français de
contrôler l'état ne sera bafoué ne
pourra pas être respecté
au fond vous savez ça c'est la pointe
ultime de notre travail notre travail
il n'a pas consisté principalement à
faire ça il a consisté à examiner
méticuleusement comment l'état a
fonctionné depuis le 1er mai je dois
dire que jamais il n'y aurait eu
d'affaires benalla cl d'eau mais ce
monsieur avait été licencié comme ils
auraient dû l'être
et si la justice avait été saisie il a
fallu attendre tout de même que la
presse rende publique la faire pour que
des réactions commencent à se faire jour
et quand on voit que ces réactions par
exemple un licenciement quand on rend
pas ses instruments de travail par an
son passeport diplomatique et un
téléphone crypté qui est un instrument
très secret mais pourquoi est ce que il
n'y a pas eu toutes les diligences pour
pour qui rendre ces passeports pour
l'empêcher de s'en servir pour qu'il
rentre et andré l'exécutif qui pointe un
problème de cohérence on entendu edouard
philippe qui dit pourquoi vous créer une
commission denquête pour la faire
benalla et pas pour
les actes pédophiles présumés dans
l'église catholique
là tout l'exécutif montent au créneau en
dise on en fait vous faites de la
politique je veux bien répondre à ça
parce que d'abord c'est quand même très
curieux alors que tout parlementaire
appartient à une famille politique il a
des convictions ils les expriment de
dire que parce qu'on appartient à une
famille politique on serait disqualifiée
pour faire son travail de législateur ou
de contrôle de l'état ça n'a pas de sens
évidemment
et la deuxième chose que je voudrais
dire puisque on évoque d'autres demandes
de commission d' enquête que nous avons
futé c'est que précisément nous avons
refusé cela parce que nous sommes
cohérents vous savez que dans cette
affaire qui concerne l'église catholique
il ya des poursuites judiciaires nous
allons pas nous mettre à examiner des
questions qui font l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires
et il y avait des poursuites du nous
avons enquête dans la sphère bénin oui
mais nous n'avons pas posé de questions
qui touchent aux poursuites judiciaires
depuis toujours dans les commissions d
enquête
on peut demander à quelqu'un qui est mis
en examen de s'exprimer mais pas sur les
questions qui relève de l' enquête
judiciaire
et ça moi je suis très sourcilleux là
dessus et j'ai fait très attention et
les rapporteurs muriel jourda et jean
pierre sueur on était très sourcilleux
et justement parce que nous sommes
cohérents nous refusons d commission
denquête quand c'est du judiciaire et
nous faisons des commissions dans 4
quand il s'agit de contrôler le bon
fonctionnement de l'état alors j'ai
juste je voudrais juste apporter une
précision
savez vous que la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale portait sur les
actes commis par monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz le 1er mai c'est à dire
précisément des actes qui faisait
l'objet d'une enquête judiciaire
et savez vous que le 18 juillet puis le
vin le 19 juillet puis le 23 juillet
madame belloubet que nous avons entendu
tout à l'heure a écrit comme elle devait
le faire elle a eu raison de faire une
lettre à mon homologue présidente de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale pour lui dire vous ne pouvez
pas enquêter là dessus
ces couverts par l'enquêté judiciaire en
revanche madame belloubet et très
justement aussi ne nous a jamais écrit
tout simplement parce
nous ne travaillons pas sur des faits
qui font l'objet d'enquêtés alors fait
pas comme ça nous sommes est
scrupuleusement nous interpréter cette
mobilisation de tous les marcheurs de
l'exécutif jusqu'à peut-être emmanuel
macron il se peut que l'élysée finissent
par réagir aussi à ce rapport dans les
prochains jours comment vous interpréter
cette mobilisation qu est ce que vous
vous dites mais moi je recommande à tous
ceux qui voudront bien lire notre
rapport de regarder sereinement la
manière dont nous analysons des
défaillances et des dysfonctions il
voyait des arrière pensées politiques de
la part de l'éguille 1 vous voudrait-il
affaiblir le sénat bien vouloir vous
dira tout bien pesé
s'ils considèrent que même s'il y a eu
des dérives individuelles de monsieur
benalla où monsieur kraz si cette dérive
donc pas en réalité était favorisé par
un manque de vigilance un manque
d'encadrement et un manque de réactivité
quand on constatait les les événements
ces défaillances là je ne dis pas que il
faut leur donner une importance
disproportionnée mais c'est pas moi qui
contribue à donner cette importance se
sont juste comment vous l'intérêt
certain nombre d'actions mais sa
démarche
ça ne m'intéresse que va créer par
exemple que ce soit une manière
d'affaiblir le sénat le riguier crédit
n'est que je me comporte comme d'autres
qui veulent faire de la polémique à
partir de cela alors que moi je dis que
je ne commente pas les commentaires j'en
reste aux faits et je crois que s'il ya
eu peut-être un minimum de crédit
accordées par les français à nos travaux
c'est précisément parce que nous n'avons
jamais accepté de rentrer dans les
polémiques dans lesquelles on voulait
nous nous a tiré larmes aussi libre que
vous dit gérard larcher
mais pourquoi me direz t-il quoi que ce
soit imagine que vous avez changé avec
lui depuis la publication devrait geler
des conversations vous avez son soutien
pour juger nous dira si oui ou non ils
vous soutiens évidemment vous avez quel
d'écouté neutre et je n'ai pas besoin de
vous le dire le travail du sénat est au
travail et des commissions donc la
tendance est tout le temps
nous avons l'habitude de faire ce
travail nous avons l'habitude de faire
des auditions
nous avons l'habitude dû prendre de
prendre du recul nous avons l'habitude
de rester calme et serein
vont aussi l'habitude de ne pas nous
laisser attirer dans des polémiques qui
nous ferait descendre d'un étage
eh bien on va s'arrêter là merci
infiniment philippe bas d'avoir accepté
de répondre à nos questions ce soir dans
vpn président de la commission des lois
sénateurs l ère de la manche plat